[Musique]
bonjour je suis Sabine Tirel je suis
écrivain scénariste de BD peintre
ancienne conseillère principale
d'éducation et présidente de l'UDA
membre aussi de l'Académie de l'île de
la Réunion
[Musique]
j'aime m'expliquer j'aime le contact
avec les autres et comme je suis
curieuse j'apprends toujours des tas de
choses et une fois que je sais j'ai
envie de partager avec d'autres
personnes je suis passionné d'histoire
de patrimoine de tout ce qui touche à la
réunion de son origine et à son devenir
je suis engagé disons culturellement et
moi j'apprends je cherche je lis je
fouille donc je partage donc de par mes
tableaux la peinture c'est une passion
déjà c'est aussi c'est nostalgique c'est
pas la réunion d'aujourd'hui c'est la
réunion qui a été et qui devrait rester
encore un peu comme ça on a besoin de ça
pour exister et savoir d'où on vient
pour pouvoir justement aller où on veut
aller j'ai eu envie d'écrire un livre
sur l'esclavage j'ai écrit noir café
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait aussi
l'engagisme donc j'ai écrit un livre sur
les engagés indiens j'aillard langage et
indienne et la dernière bande dessinée
que j'ai écrite c'est le mousse de la
Méduse et c'est pareil un livre qui
parle de la colonisation que je touche
tous les publics c'est ça l'important
c'est qu'on apprenne sans apprendre
comme maintenant je suis présidente de
l'UDA en 2001 des artistes de la réunion
et on essaye tous les ans de faire une
action
patrimoniale ou historique
que le patrimoine soit partagé qui soit
abordable et qu'ils soient pas réservé
que pendant les journées du patrimoine
le patrimoine c'est aussi des des
visites dans les musées c'est aussi
comme ça pourquoi on libère pas je sais
pas pourquoi on n'ouvre pas les musées
gratuitement aux gens
[Musique]
donc je m'appelle Aïcha ou qui est je
suis directrice adjointe du pôle
d'établissement médico-sociaux Edmond
Albus géré par la Lefa la laisse pas
c'est l'association laïque pour
l'éducation la formation la prévention
et l'autonomie
en plus de mon métier en fait de
directrice adjointe j'anime un groupe de
sportifs depuis 2013 donc ce groupe de
sportifs ce sont des sportifs en
situation de handicap
et là l'idée c'était de permettre à des
personnes à ces personnes de pouvoir
accéder à une pratique de haut niveau
puisque là il s'agit de trail et de
course à pied voire de Marathon donc là
on est dans du sport de haut niveau et
en plus d'y avoir accès comme tout le
monde c'est-à-dire sans étiquette sans
être stigmatisé sans être dans une
catégorie
handicap ce projet on l'a appelé nos
cours comme zot nous courons comme vous
en créole réunionnais donc c'est un
projet qui repose sur un groupe de
bénévoles et là tout le monde est court
tout le monde court même moi je cours il
y a de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont attirées par ce projet-là et qui
ont envie de courir et puis celles qui
sont déjà dans le projet ont envie de
continuer à faire le tour du monde en
courant en fait c'était ça le truc
c'était ça donc c'est aussi découvrir
des personnes qui parlent pas du tout la
même langue que nous découvrez des
monnaies qui sont différentes en termes
de découverte c'est c'est des choses qui
ne pourraient pas faire si dans un autre
cadre quoi c'est c'est vraiment de
découvrir notre pays et en même temps
améliorer ses compétences sportives
améliorer ses compétences sociales
[Musique]
il faut que je sois toujours occupé et
il faut toujours que il faut que je
m'éclate dans ce que je fais enfin voilà
je suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement
dynamique
[Musique]
et ce que j'aimerais c'est que c'est que
tous les enfants à l'école avec les
autres enfants que les personnes en
situation de handicap puisse travailler
comme les autres personnes dans le
milieu ordinaire et pas dans un milieu
ségrégué comme le nôtre enfin c'est une
vision idéaliste mais ce que j'aimerais
dans l'avenir c'est ça
[Musique]
Anita Turl présidente de l'Olympique
Club s'attendre les léopards
63 ans et retraités
[Musique]
parce que ça fait 40 ans que je suis
dans le foot je vais pas lâcher et que
c'est mon club de cœur
loyal par rapport à mon club parce que
c'est
je suis membre fondateur de ce club
sincère
intuitive aussi parce que il faut
absolument connaître qui on a affaire
rapidement dans le foot où il est
souvent encensé alors que les gens
l'aient un petit peu hypocrite aussi des
fois
[Musique]
la mère de famille et comme un club
c'est une grande famille on a besoin une
femme comme une maman pour nous donner
des directives et aussi choyer les
joueurs et aussi mettre une ambiance
familiale au sein du club et quand on
voit le travail que la présidentielle
envie de continuer alors cette année
nous l'envoyer un jeune faire des essais
à Montpellier Hérault
et il a signé un contrat là pour trois
ans et d'ici juillet 2019 ben il sera
stagiaire pro à 17 ans
mon rêve ce serait que le football dans
les si grandit que nous ramène des
titres dans l'est parce que le football
est quand même pas dans le secteur qu'on
continue avec
nos jeunes la formation des jeunes pour
qu'ils puissent s'ils en ont la capacité
va évoluer dans des grands clubs et puis
toujours les amener à sortir à côtoyer
[Musique]
Nathalie qui pend dédiée à 54 ans très
jeune elle perd ses parents et grandit à
Saint Paul entouré de ses frères et
soeurs musiciens qui accueillait
beaucoup d'artistes à la maison alors
qu'elle est en activité dans le domaine
social elle participe en tant que
bénévole alors organisation de la grande
manifestation culturelle carba réunion
en 1996 et 1997 c'est dans ce contexte
qu'elle rejoint le groupe scagans comme
manager de 1996 à 1998 elle organisera
des tournées internationales pour le
groupe de 1997 à 2005 elle intègre
l'équipe du séchoir en qualité de
programmatrice Music et dense où elle
met en place plusieurs événements comme
le Saint-Leu dans ce festival le battle
hip-hop de Saint-Leu et le festival
Sakifo en 2005 elle est programmatrice
est chargée de production du festival de
danse de Saint-Denis elle deviendra
ensuite chargée de la programmation du
cabardoch au port
la qualité et la diversité de ces choix
artistiques feront le succès de cette
salle de spectacle la qualité de
l'accueil qu'elle réserve aux artistes
depuis plus de 20 ans a fait la
réputation de Nathalie qui pend dédiée
dans les plus importantes sociétés de
production française et étrangères en
2008 elle devient membre du jurifère et
depuis 2015 elle est membre du comité
d'experts musique et danse de la dacoï
parmi les plus grands artistes musiciens
qu'elle a accueilli à la Réunion au
cabardoch ou dans le cadre du festival
opus Pocus on peut citer Gilberto Gil
Césaria Evora Marcus Miller Nathalie
kippendaitier c'est ainsi construit un
vaste réseau professionnel
particulièrement dans les domaines du
jazz et des musiques du monde elle est
sans doute la seule programmatrice de
l'île à disposer d'un tel réseau avec la
crise du covid 19 Nathalie n'a pas
ménagé ses efforts pour finaliser ses
programmes et adapter selon les
possibilités de la conjoncture un
accueil limité notamment les après-midi
des weekends ce qui fait qu'elle ne
connaît pas de répit loin d'abandonner
c'est avec résilience et volonté qu'elle
se projette dans un retour à la normale
pour faire de sa programmation une offre
de qualité reconnue par tous
[Musique]
Sabine le Toullec enseignante à la
retraite qu'est-ce que je fais je
m'occupe de l'association bien sûr
d'association absent
nous avons créé cette association il y a
32 ans cette association est née de la
volonté d'une assistante maternelle elle
recevait des enfants handicapés et elle
ne savait pas quoi faire avec eux et on
a commencé à travailler quand on est
emmené ces jeunes sur le terrain ici
même d'ailleurs à l'embraskis ben
c'était comme si c'était le siècle
Brazil qui était de sortie les gens
s'agglutinaient autour pour regarder et
donc nous on a dit c'est pas possible il
faut absolument qu'on fasse connaître
les personnes handicapées qu'on
travaille avec eux pour changer ce
regard ce regard des gens qui n'avaient
jamais vu et nous ça nous embêter et
d'autant plus que moi-même j'ai un fils
portion de handicap et nous on a pris la
valorisation par le sport comment
changer le regard des personnes sur ces
gens mais comment aussi changer le
regard de ces personnes handicapées sur
elle-même parce que elle elle se
trouvait vraiment méprisée dévalorisée
et oh le sport c'est un formidable
vecteur c'est quand on réussit ne
serait-ce qu'à mettre un ballon dans un
panier et que tout le monde fait ouah
ouah ouah on se sent pousser des ailes
c'est ce qui s'est passé petit à petit
petit à petit les jeunes ont connu la
réussite connaissant la réussite ils ont
voulu aller plus loin connaissant un
sport ils ont voulu faire d'autres
sports d'autres activités Clarisse qui
était une athlète de chez nous plusieurs
fois championne en athlétisme médaille
donne athlétisme elle a été au marathon
de New York donc installé aux États-Unis
en Irlande en Grèce on a rapporté des
médailles des médailles d'or aux Jeux
spécial olympiques faut avoir beaucoup
de physique et d'endurance et après il
faut beaucoup s'entraîner pour devenir
champion après voilà mon but c'est de
venir dans les plus encore plus loin
[Musique]
alors nos activités il y a de
l'athlétisme le VTT la natation la
pétanque et la Zumba
ont mené par un éducateur spécialisé non
seulement on a créé l'association pour
les jeunes mais on a quand il
l'association pour les familles parce
que souvent les familles ont un
sentiment de culpabilité et donc on a dû
quand même on a pris des professionnels
pour montrer à ses familles que il y a
pas la culpabilité ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui d'avoir un enfant porté
aux handicap
je pense que c'est c'est mon caractère
parce que quand on aide quelqu'un on
aide aussi soi-même parce que moi aussi
j'étais dans le doute quand j'ai eu un
enfant moi j'ai eu dans le doute mais
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir de bons
professionnels qui m'ont bien accompagné
donc c'est pour ça maintenant que je
peux mettre ce que je j'ai reçu je peux
mettre ça aussi à vis des autres
le département comme on dit toujours
c'est du premier des premiers cris au
dernier soupir sans le département sans
ses actions
comme je dis toujours rien n'est parfait
de l'important c'est de le savoir et on
va désaméliorations certes c'est pas
suffisant mais nous sommes dans la bonne
voie
je suis une personne à mobilité réduite
donc je suis né avec un handicap de
naissance handicapé moteur donc chaque
handicap à sa catégorie et moi c'est
vraiment au niveau de la moelle épinière
qui me permet en fait niveau
neurologiquement de ne pas pouvoir
utiliser mes jambes mais je me porte
très bien au niveau mental je suis
parfaitement équilibrée et en bonne
santé alors j'ai fait mes études de BEP
et de bac pro secrétariat au lycée Léon
perven Duport donc mon intégration ça
s'est fait au début un peu difficile
parce que forcément il faut mettre des
aides techniques en place pour m'aider
dans dans le métier que j'avais choisi
qui était le secrétariat l'intégration à
l'école quand on est différent c'est
difficile car on est confronté au regard
des autres de certaines personnes qui
sont en manque de connaissance et qui ne
savent pas ce que c'est que le handicap
c'est comme quelqu'un qui est obèse ou
qui est de couleur de peau différente on
est confronté à ce genre de propos qui
nous blesse nous en tant que personne en
tant que être humain mais grâce à tout
ça ça a fait de cette faiblesse que j'ai
à fait ma force aujourd'hui et je montre
aux autres qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur
de nous faut pas avoir peur du handicap
mais au-delà de ça et encore beaucoup de
bonnes personnes bienveillantes et
respectueuses qui viennent vers moi et
qui m'aide et qui m'accompagne dans ma
vie ce qui m'a vraiment aidé dans à
m'accepter comme je suis c'est le
soutien inconditionnel de ma famille et
de mes vrais amis et bien évidemment ce
qui a complété mon mon acheminement dans
dans mon parcours c'est le handisport je
suis venu à Sainte-Marie habiter ici
pour avoir un nouveau départ et ce
nouveau départ je l'ai trouvé à travers
le handping avec mon club à la
Cressonnière à Saint-André grâce à mon
président Nelson fontaine et à la
responsable de handisport comité réunion
Annick à makucci donc qui ont mis en
place le handping à la Réunion pour nous
aider nous en tant handicapés à faire le
tennis de table et c'est un sport qui
m'aide vraiment à m'épanouir et à faire
de belles par contre y avoir de belles
relations en plus j'ai fait mes
premières compètes donc je suis arrivée
deuxième championnat régional de La
Réunion et je me projette éventuellement
avec mon club d'aller au championnat de
France et de faire connaître encore plus
le handiping de la Réunion en métropole
et de mettre la Réunion en l'air en tant
que personne à mobilité réduite quand on
a un handicap on doit faire plus
d'efforts plus de travail plus de
mouvement plus de réflexion par rapport
à notre projet par rapport à notre
travail et par rapport au sport et par
rapport à notre vie de tous les jours ça
nous demande beaucoup plus de ténacité
et de rigueur et de force et de courage
et même parfois c'est difficile mais
avec de la persévérance on arrive à
atteindre notre objectif et ce que je
souhaite à tous les personnes à mobilité
réduite de réaliser leurs rêves et leurs
projets au-delà de leur handicap
[Musique]